at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by four Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it if too much of a headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
and or nutmilk such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
she take the advice of all Chinese
people when they're criticizing young
uns when they say boo and I'm sugar cool
which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this ratio lecture on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and know
don't put it in honey or nut milk or any
of that [ __ ] just drink the goddamn tea
it's delicious I think right if you like
puer that kind of stuff that type of tea
you're gonna dig it so just try it okay
back to then my read if you'd like to
naturally improve your sleep both on set
and quality I think naturally you might
just enjoy this ratio lecture without
any sweeteners it has organic reishi
extract organic fueled mint extract
organic rosehips extract organic Tulsi
extract and that's it no fancy stuff no
artificial whatchamacallit anything so
check it out go to four sigma tech comm
forward slash Ferriss and get 20% off
this special batch I don't know if
they're gonna be making much more of
this since it was made specifically for
you guys so do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for sig Matic that's fo you are SI GMA t
IC comm /e ferrous f e RR ISS and get
20% off the special batch and you must
use the code Ferris to receive a
discount fer our ISS so again go to four
sig Metacom forward slash Ferris and
then use code Ferris for 20% off of this
rare exclusive limited run of reishi
mushroom elixir for nighttime routines
without any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet Friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers and it's
super super simple
it does not clog up your inbox every
Friday I send out five bullet points
super short of the coolest things I've
found that week which sometimes includes
apps books documentaries supplements
gadgets new self experiments hacks
tricks and all sorts of weird stuff that
I dig up from around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long and that's
why I created five bullet Friday it's
become one of my favorite things I do
every week it's free it's always gonna
be free and you can learn more at tim
dot blog forward slash friday
that's Tim dot blog forward slash Friday
I get asked a lot how I meet guests for
the podcast some of the most amazing
people I've ever interacted with and a
little known fact I've met probably 25%
of them because they first subscribe to
fine bullet Friday so you'll be in good
company it's a lot of fun five bullet
Friday is only available if you
subscribe via email I do not publish the
content on the blog or anywhere else
also if I'm doing small in-person
meetups offering early access to
startups beta-testing special deals or
anything else that's very limited I
share it first with 500 Friday
subscribers so check it out
Tim blog forward slash Friday if you
listen to this podcasts very likely that
you'd dig it a lot and you can of course
easily subscribe any time so easy peasy
again that's Tim blog forward slash
Friday and thanks for checking it out if
the spirit moves you
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show long time no see long
time no hear
how do pitch in or should I say how do
meio ting down you they sang in that
something along those lines little rusty
but I digress the Tim Ferriss show is
typically where I share the habits and
routines of world-class performers as
well as try to spot and discuss the
patterns amongst them this episode is
gonna be a role reversal and since I am
a professional dilettante professional
amateur of sorts a little self-conscious
about this however recently Cal fuss men
at Cal fuss manaphy us SMA an the man
who has transformed oral history into an
art form
that's not my quote and it's not his
that's what people say about him because
he's interviewed everyone from Clooney
to Gorbachev to Reagan to you name it
he's a big deal and he is also one of
the principal writers or was one of the
senior writers behind the what I learned
column for Esquire magazine forever just
how he got to kick the tires and meet
many of these folks interviewed me for
his podcast he interviewed me in two
separate interviews and in true kal
fashion he took the conversation to
places I never could have expected he
really is a master of the craft of
asking questions and I love speaking
with him as a friend but I also love
studying him as an interviewer Cal said
this interview was one of his favorites
he's ever heard from me because the way
he put it was quote we get to learn what
made Tim Tim end quote we dug into some
of the childhood stories that I
typically hold back I don't like to talk
about some of the early days and
childhood stuff but Cal can pry it out
of me Cal said he wanted to build a
story to understand what happened to me
on my journey how it explains where I am
now what makes me tick and where I still
hope to improve and grow and I think he
was able to unearth all of that so if
you're looking for a true world-class
performer someone who is the best at
what they do then you
look for one of my other episodes Tim
don't blog forward-slash podcast there's
300 other people you could find Jamie
Fox you can find held sorts and Egger
you can find chess prodigies like Josh
Waitzkin but if you want to hear about
my somewhat odd maybe quirky path that
took me from my days as a wee lad to
where I am now then this may be an
episode of interest Cal is really really
a fascinating specimen and I've
interviewed him twice if you want to
hear Cal side of the story
his entire insane meandering adventure
of life which includes taking shots with
Hunter s Thompson and working alongside
Hunter for a period of time you can hear
that at tim dot blog forward slash cal
and you should absolutely listen to more
of Cal's interviews so check out his new
podcast for which I was interviewed big
questions with Cal fuss men so just
Google big questions with Cal fuss man
fu SS a man where he interviews all
sorts of folks like Kobe Bryant and
Daymond John and Seth Godin and on and
on and on and then there's me odd man
out so without further ado and preamble
I'm kind of stalling with this intro I
apologize guys here is my interview aka
being interviewed by Cal fuss man it
just went off to springboard rather just
went off the springboard so I've been
thinking about this conversation for a
long time and I basically had two ways
to prepare I thought like one I know you
we've been in the sauna together we have
met your mom that's right
met your dad we've gone out to eat you
won't let me pick up the check
listen to your podcasts read your books
so I do in some ways know you and I
thought well I could do even more
research or I could try to just
wipe my memory clean and approach this
in a way that I really don't know Tim
and I'm gonna try and forget a little
about what I know and just act like I
bumped him to Tim Ferriss on the train
holy [ __ ] Tim Ferriss are you doing
you're pretty good at trains for my turn
my memory today good at trains so and
it's funny when I went out to see you I
went on a train and so I thought that
would be an interesting way to go and
the more I think about it the thing that
really hits me about you
goes to a story about Brian Grazer and
Ron Howard okay so once a producer and
the other is a filmmaker they're
partners and I'm interviewing them in
the Claridge Hotel in London and we're
talking we're having a great
conversation and in the middle of this
interview a fire alarm goes off and
water sprouts from the ceiling in an
instant
Ron Howard rushes to it was like sort of
a kitchen in this room and he grabs a
bucket and he puts it under the water at
the same time Ron Howard ran to the
bathroom and got the towels and had them
down and I was just amazed at how they
both in a second went in their own
directions to solve the problem and
together they came up with the solution
while I just sat there watching this and
the more I thought about it I thought
the genius of Tim Ferriss is he does
both at the same time you're like two
people who would you wouldn't ordinarily
need a partner
to do the things that you do and yet you
have these skills on different sides of
the spectrum that reside inside you and
I'm thinking how did that happen so
let's start at the beginning I was
talking yesterday - this guy wim HOF oh
yeah oh yes there you go I don't win
okay now he goes underwater and this
stays under the cold for minutes at a
time
and when I was asking him how this came
about he explained when he was born he
was born a twin the second twin and he
came out like basically deprived of
oxygen and he didn't know it until years
later but his whole life became a
movement toward the moment he was born
with and I'm wondering at your birth did
something happened that helped make you
who you are it's quite possible I don't
remember all too much but as I've been
told I was born premature and ended up
in critical care I still have scars you
can actually see one right on my wrist
there looks like a cigarette burn oh oh
yeah yeah yeah I have another one
underneath my left nipple basically it's
in the rib area and that is from a
respirator I had as I understand it five
full-body blood transfusions to
oxygenate the blood properly and I was
in a really bad shape I'm very very very
tiny and under incubator lights and so
on so I had a lot of I suppose trauma
but difficulty coming into the world and
seemed to have recovered very very very
small up until about the end of fifth
grade very small kid very much a run
so has your life has been a good part of
it spent in search of getting the most
out of your body and definitely there's
a pretty good relation well there is in
in some direct ways in the sense that
the experimentation and the recording of
experiments started with primarily
wrestling which was the only sport I
really gravitated to towards or actually
did well in I was very hyperactive as a
kid and there were some other mothers
who recommended to my mom to drain my
batteries to put me into something
called kid wrestling I couldn't do or I
really didn't want to do other sports
that were team sports because I was so
small I would get I was bullied and beat
up and couldn't compete I couldn't hold
my own with other kids but weight weight
classes exist in wrestling
so the puny and little runt could battle
the other puny little runt and then one
of them could feel like a winner for a
short period of time before they went
back to school and got the crap kicked
out of them once again so I was put into
kid wrestling and there was really
there's not much technical mastery a
little kid in kid wrestling it's mostly
just flopping around but at some point
in high school
certainly and just before high school
began taking it very seriously and I
still to this day have some very serious
thermo regulatory issues so I I don't
respond to heat in a normal way how do
you respond to heat I appear to have and
I've actually done a number of
experiments and been involved in
experiments to try to better understand
it I'm very sensitive to say heat stroke
but it doesn't appear because I at one
point much much later after college
volunteered to be a test subject and we
have bounced around a little bit here at
Stanford University where they were
developing a glove for cooling the body
and it was being developed or at least
funded by the military
so the general experiment included wear
full military fatigues helmet loaded
backpack and you had an esophageal probe
as you would imagine down your nose so
it's about I would say two feet long and
it's a it's a plastic tube that you feed
down your nose down your esophagus so
your throat can't close or your
epiglottis can't close down to get your
core body temperature from your heart so
you get as close to the heart as
possible unfortunately for me the
military standard temperature gauge is a
soft geo probe but up the other end so I
also had probe of the other end and then
you go oh it gets better and I knew we
were gonna get deep beer I'm just
jumping right into it that's not much
for play in this podcast and I then had
to go into a sauna I don't recall the
exact temperature and March on an
incline treadmill in the sauna to heat
exhaustion and this was done multiple
times and they would track everything
and what was up well I should say in
retrospect should have been expected it
was miserable of course and then I was
completely non-functional for the rest
of the day because my brain had
effectively shut off when you March to
heat exhaustion but I hit that heat
exhaustion shutdown point at lower
temperatures than other people
so I think it's something in the brain
maybe there's some gauge in the
hypothalamus or something that is off
but suffice to say throughout even high
school I and we can come back to this
but when I was in Japan which was a real
formative moment was hospitalized for
effectively heatstroke during a judo
competition or training in the summer
because I was overheating so all of that
is backstory to say that really early on
I realized that heat was not my friend
and endurance was not my strong suit I
just couldn't last I would overheat in
these wrestling matches so I had to
develop techniques and approaches why
other tricks like getting very good at
cutting weight so that I could level the
playing field to actually compete and
win in these sports so if you could
figure out how to really be 15 pounds
heavier than you were it would give me a
fair shot right yeah and it certainly is
an advantage but I had other
disadvantages so it it would but it was
it was an area where I realized most
people were not spending a lot of time
analyzing anything or that's a very
fancy way to put it it was it was just a
low-hanging fruit for me because I was
like alright well I'm never going to be
the most technical wrestler I'm never
gonna be the most persistent wrestler in
terms of endurance because I lack the
physiology for it but how many wrestlers
are really gonna sit down and try to
figure out sodium and potassium oh and
read about potassium sparing diuretics
and to figure out that dandelion root is
something that you know a
fifteen-year-old can actually get a hold
of over-the-counter which act which has
the properties of certain prescription
medications which should achieve the
same thing etc etc where did that come
from uh I've always at least from high
school been fascinated by nutrition and
that does not come from my family I know
it's funny because one of the things it
when I think of your dad yeah I always
think of the advertising slogan he came
up with
fill your belly at big Dave's deli
that's right that's right and I won't
want to get into the particulars of my
family too much just for privacy
purposes but yeah I mean my I would not
say that my parents are nutritional
advisors to Olympians they're taking
better care of themselves but they
didn't come from there I honestly don't
know exactly where it came from it could
have been I'll just speculate here I've
never actually thought about it
which is a good sign in an interview
that I was a puny little runt and I was
I was born in seven in the late 70s and
then grew up in the 80s well who were
the stars in the 80s you have
Schwarzenegger Van Damme well oh man
they're all these ripped that was the
golden era of action films if you think
about you know what I was out of the
country then I missed it all makes sense
well to start the plots are pretty easy
to follow so if you wanted to go back
killed you lost I lied it's very easy to
digest material now I understand the
opening of your podcast exactly yeah
makes more sense oh man so there's one
other fact that I just didn't like to
bring out because to me is it's very
interesting
there's it was like a salesmanship and
inside your dad you and your mom you
come into the house and hey sit down
let's peel some shrimp and have some
dinner yeah there is a very welcoming
quality to her for sure and both of
these you what you have there yeah
they're very different they're very
different people and as long as yeah as
long as long as we're talking about
characteristics I'm fine with it the
give another anecdote which shows the
difference so my my dad loves crossword
puzzles my mom is just incredibly good
at who also crossword puzzles about
Wheel of Fortune so their minds worked
very differently I mean she could see
one letter and she'll get it in ten
milliseconds and I don't my father also
has and you've experienced this the
closest thing to the closest thing to
perfect factual recall that I've ever
encountered up close for extended
periods of time
I mean he remembers the
where every classmate of his sat in
every class he had in elementary school
he remembers every word
fill-in-the-blank language that he
learned in fifth grade and I do not have
that I also don't have the say within 10
milliseconds answer will a fortune
answer ability of my mom but it stands
to reason that if I'm getting genetics
from both sides I'm somewhere in the
middle but but what you do have is the
ability to make people feel comfortable
around you which if you're interviewing
people so you got to have the items to
help and and also you understand how to
sell what you do so like pieces are
starting to come together here
can the may I add another piece sure
please do so I don't know I don't think
I've ever told you this so alright so
how did I become interested in
persuasion and selling and so on I've
always been a night owl my mom's theory
is so I've always I mean since I was a
very very very little kid gone to bed
typically 2 3 4 a.m. my mom's theory is
because that's that that is due to being
under incubator lights at night in the
the intensive care unit or the critical
care unit in the hospital as a new work
so constantly under under lights at
night and what kind of television is on
at 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and for
appeal commercials I'd be up late at
night and it's all paid programming I
couldn't go to sleep and there would be
these Ron Popeil let's fill in the blank
it's Tony Robbins and I just became
fascinated by and asked myself why
someone would buy one of these things
and at the time of course I'm not
interested in making money
not interested in building a business
I'm a little kid but nonetheless oh
that's a big piece you got there you got
the pocket fisherman you've got the
topic hair powder that you pour on your
head
remembering this like your dad would
have yeah I mean I do have I have a very
visual memory so my my dad has not just
visual but also very textual if that
makes sense and I know that's coming
through the optic system but I tend to
remember anything that engages color and
motion very well which can creep people
out because I'll be like oh yeah they'll
be hey we've met before yeah I remember
meeting because we were sitting here and
there and your third chair from the left
and you were wearing this and that
especially the the spider-sense for
psycho goes off in their head which is
is not well founded in this case it's
just the memory that a particular type
of memory that I have but that yeah lots
of late nights listening to guy I I
don't remember his work with Sir Robert
Peel I became later interested in going
back and figuring out who these people
were right so you had for instance the
ThighMaster you probably member the
thought I do remember that that man and
the whole story behind that and then Ron
Popeil who who cut his teeth at state
fairs a lot of these old old-timers the
kind of ground breakers in him vomer
shalls'
cut their teeth at these various state
fairs selling to live disinterested
audiences who are walking by so they'd
have to get attention and first get a
crowd and then sell the product right so
there was a multi-stage process and they
had then translated that television
which is why almost all these products
initially were live demo products right
which Tony Robbins differed from and so
that interested me I'm like alright well
everyone else is doing the slice and
dice i can cut through a can and then i
can cut through a tomato because it
didn't dull the knife and as a kid of
course I don't have no desire to buy a
knife but I'm looking at the demo and
then you have say
Tony Robbins or maybe a handful of
others but really not many who weren't
selling a physical product and that was
interesting to me or like the
no-money-down real estate stuff which
made even less sense to me than anything
else I'm like well alright I don't even
know where to begin
understanding that conceptually but
they're using this guy who's selling
whatever no money down real estate is is
using a thousand testimonials ok so he's
only using testimonials that's
interesting why is he doing that
oh man see this this is what fascinates
me because for what you just said about
first get the crowd then sell the
product is very different from the way a
writer or an artist things where they're
saying I want to do I got to do this
somebody's got to help me do it somebody
give me some money and and allow me to
fulfill my dream and they don't stop to
think well let me get a crowd first and
then I can do what I want to do so let
me add another layer to this which is so
that's my life from midnight to 3
o'clock in the morning the rest of the
time I from a very very young age wanted
to be a comic book penciler so I wanted
to be an artist I literally wanted to be
an artist I wanted to be an illustrator
oh you are two people and I spent all of
my time drawing and that was my goal was
to become a comic book penciler and as
idolized certain artists at the time
specifically pencil errs like Jim Lee
who I've been actually yeah it's at some
point about a year ago we were trading
email to hopefully have me interview him
which would be a lot of fun
and MacFarlane and Eric Larsen and I
could go down the list Simon Bisley all
of these artists were those were the
people I idolized from a career
standpoint I didn't even think about it
as a career but as as to what I wanted
to do since I enjoyed drawing and seemed
to have a predisposition towards it
that was what I spent the rest of my
time thinking about so you had school
wrestling comic book penciling and then
I can't sleep what should I do
infomercials now I'm beginning to get
the pieces are coming together here
brother because I look at myself and
like I am missing I am missing pieces
here I wasn't up at 3:00 in the morning
watching the infomercials now there are
downsides to that I mean it's not all oh
no no but think about think about what
that gave you this then the notion of
get the crowd first then sell the
product yeah that puts you in control
yeah totally
which most artists are there they're out
of control they're always looking for
the manager or the publishing house or
the record company to support their
dream yeah and from the beginning I want
it to be control was really important to
me from that I mean very beginning and
not talking about career aspirations but
just trying to control as many variables
as possible people think of me is some
type of risk-taker with the early stage
startups and everything else I don't
view myself that way at all I think
about mitigating and decreasing risk all
the time so for me I like to have
control directly or indirectly over as
many variables as possible that's not
always a strength but at least for me up
to up to this point it's there have been
a lot of benefits certainly how does
money fit into the equation when you
were in high school how did you see
money
once you start working so I think my
first job was 13 or 14 and I was the
floor and machine cleaner at an ice
cream shop called snowflake which no
longer exists out on Long Island I grew
up and for people who don't know I grew
up as a townie in the Hamptons which is
a weird place to grow up so to grow up
as sort of the rat tail wearing county
in a resort town anywhere in the world
is pretty odd and that at that time I
was getting paid who knows whatever was
like seven or eight dollars an hour and
actually no I don't I don't know if it
was per hour I think it was per shift
because that's what's got me in trouble
is I got fired from this first job
because they I think it was per shift
that I was getting paid because
otherwise I wouldn't have been incentive
eyes to do what I'm about to tell you if
they're paying me per hour I wouldn't
have wanted I wouldn't have had any
interest in doing things faster yeah so
I I was being told to do things in a
stupid way it was stupid
like I'm not gonna mince words it was
just I was being told to do things in a
very inefficient way so that I would be
kept busy for the entire period of time
this was not of great interest to me and
seemed stupid so I for myself at least
devisor I thought was a much better way
much faster way of cleaning cleaning the
machines and the floors and so on and
then I would always bring to work god I
haven't thought about this in a while a
copy of black belt magazine which was
the only martial arts the the the most
widely read martial arts magazine at the
time this is before any mixed martial
arts or anything it entered the scene
and then I would take my mop like the
mop handle and just like practice
made-up martial arts stuff I didn't know
what I was doing like in the back
parking lot where no one would see me so
I'd do my work necessary my work is done
that kind of be Bruce Lee yeah and then
it's like alright well now give
that you know the next whatever it is
Van Damme movie is coming out next week
I just seen the latest Stallone movie
and I still weigh and you know one
hundred and hundred pounds I need to
work on becoming Bruce Lee
needless to say the boss was not super
fond of this and so he would tell me to
do things like alright well I want you
to clean it again and I'd say well it's
already clean you know the floors are
clean keep in mind and that was that was
a partnership destined to fail I'm
afraid so I was I was relieved of duty
Wow
by you weeks or months in the notion of
efficiency yes planted that was the
efficiency and that was not uh
client-facing
what i mean by that is I didn't have any
interaction with the customers there
right after that my next job and and I
worked many many jobs as a busboy and
occasionally was given the gift of say
waiting for a table but I worked in
restaurants and I worked for people who
have seen the affair I think as a
Showtime show there is a restaurant in
that show called the lobster roll well I
was a busboy at the lobster all which is
one of the highest volume highest table
turnover which is a good thing in this
in that world restaurants on Long Island
certainly out on the on the East End not
I'm no offense lobster roll some people
from the city call it lunch because as a
big sign outside just FYI anybody from
Manhattan nobody calls it lunch out
there it's the lobster roll and it that
was brutal I was that was brutal I also
worked just to paint the spectrum super
look and that low-end but fast fast food
right fast high-volume and then I worked
at restaurants like the Maidstone arms
which now has a new name and many many
others in between so I had a chance in
those circumstances to say at the
Maidstone arms I remember I had to wear
a
pink was it a pink button-up shirt with
a black bowtie and needless to say I
didn't have either of those so I had to
work to afford to get your ass to get
dressed to go to work and but that gave
me the ability to interact with diners
all right so now I can contribute to
getting more tips for the table which
ultimately gets divvied up among the
people who are front of house and maybe
even back house
so the cleaning wasn't a great fit for
me
I don't think on many on several
different levels but it actually taught
you about efficiency the way you feel
about efficient or taught me how much I
hate inefficiency okay or maybe
reinforced how much I hated inefficiency
and because I'd already been thinking
about efficiency within the context of
wrestling I just hadn't realized that
that also all applied in other places
Wow right
yeah the pieces are coming together
because if you're if I'm inefficient on
the wrestling mat what happens now I'm
into the second period third period then
my body shuts down then I lose so I had
to think about efficiency I never would
have used that I never would have used
that word but that's certain comes back
to your birth ah yeah yeah I mean I
suppose I suppose gotta be it does the
most efficient to get the most out of
yourself you couldn't afford to just go
along like everybody else I know I would
lose and I don't know where the dislike
of losing came from but I certainly have
a strong dislike of love losing so
that's just doing it following standard
operating procedure just wasn't a very
attractive option to me okay so here's
one thing I do know you went to study
with John McPhee I had the gift and I'm
not going to say that I in any way
deserved it more than other kids at at
Princeton but I ended up going to
Princeton for undergrad and well they
take a second to describe who John McVie
is to those who yeah John McPhee this
may sound like a huge overstatement but
you can correct me if I'm wrong
in the minds of many nonfiction writers
I mean John McPhee is a god he is he is
no debate here the consummate master of
his craft and he's a staff writer a
longtime staff writer at the New Yorker
has at least one Pulitzer Prize I never
know if it's Pilcher Pulitzer but I like
st. Pulitzer so I'll say that like it
has to whom that's over the you which it
does not for coming into the country
specifically which was about his time
primarily in Alaska John McPhee is so
good at nonfiction writing and the class
that I ended up taking which was a small
seminar so you applied and provided
writing samples was called the
literature of fact what a great name
right yes you would expect of John
McPhee MC pH EE
he's so good exploring and dissecting
different subjects that when he writes a
book about basketball a sense of where
you are related to Bill Bradley it
becomes the classic write in nonfiction
basketball when he writes a book about
tennis levels of the game it becomes the
classic write book on tennis and it goes
on he wrote an entire book about oranges
he wrote an entire book about Iraq he's
he's written entire books about
classically carved canoes and you would
say to yourself and you may be saying to
yourself I would never read a book about
oranges oh yeah yeah you would yes you
would oh yes you would yeah and and just
just to just to dive into one of the
examples I just gave levels of the game
it's about one tennis match the entire
book is about one tennis match
conceptually it's hard for me to imagine
anything sounding more boring and yet
it is absolutely gripping as a
page-turner
and there's a lot more to it as is you
would certainly expect but well what's
it like to be in a class with a map with
an a God like this ah you know from the
Verret from the first day I felt it was
just a huge gift I mean I and I had a I
had a good degree of insecurity going
into it I mean we're talking about
someone who had David Remnick as a
student right I mean we're talking about
we're talking about teacher who has not
only produced masterpieces himself but
produce students and I'm not saying I am
not one of them but it wasn't Nick being
the editor of the new year that's right
who's produced many students who have
gone on to just create incredible
incredible works of art and I do not
think I'm that person at all but I could
draft behind a lot of those people in
the class so it not only was it a gift
to learn from Professor McPhee I can't
call him John it's too weird
they're a bunch of people in my life I
can't call by the first name it was also
a gift to hear the comments and feedback
and reading aloud of other students I do
remember very clearly so alright
Princeton students generally speaking
pretty confident Bunch
sometimes excessively so and I remember
we had this the class structure as I
remember it was I want to say one
three-hour two or three our group
seminar were lesser mcafee would talk
about a given subject some aspect of
structure which he's very well known for
and very visual very visual in his
structuring which helped me because I
like to draw right but I recall we we
also had weekly writing assignments
these were short few pages whatever was
3 to 10 pages I had already done quite a
bit of writing in school so
with that and we'd all do all handed in
our weekly writing assignments and we
were getting them back and before he
handed them back I remember he said he
would then later review our writing
assignments with us which was incredible
he said up before I hand these out
this is paraphrasing I want you to know
you're all good writers so I don't want
you to be thrown off by my edits you're
all good you got into the class and he
handed back our printed pages that we
had given him and in almost every case
certainly in my case there was more red
ink than other words everybody oh and
but you leave that class a writer well
you leave that class a better thinker
because what McPhee does so well and he
has a book that recently came out called
the fourth draft about his writing
process which is fantastic if you're
interested in non-fiction writing if
you're really interested then this book
is great if you're kind of sort of
interested in non-fiction writing more
interested in reading nonfiction then
just get levels of the game or one of
his other books but he is first and
foremost good at clarifying thoughts so
if you have extraneous words if you have
sentences that are nebulous and meaning
if you have a sequence of paragraphs
that logically do not make any sense as
a progression he'll point those out so
it really wasn't it wasn't providing you
as a fancier set of polished words to
use it wasn't a matter of anything that
could be differentiated from clarifying
your thinking and putting clearer
thinking on paper
I smell efficiency yeah yeah in a way it
certainly would be I mean in a way it
certainly would be and taking out its
and efficiency is one thing I think also
if you look at my interest in certain
martial arts if you look at my interest
in
certain wrestlers if you look at my
interest in writing I think that the the
corollary or maybe just the it's not
even a cousin it's like the twin brother
or sister of efficiency is elegance so
that's something I think about a lot
because in elegance you also have the
art it's not just the science right it's
not just the mechanics it's also the
beauty of it and for me the ability to
make something more beautiful by
removing the things that are adding to
drag is just such a cool concept all the
pieces are coming together here it's
such a cool concept and I mean now that
I'm thinking about it and yeah a
post-hoc it's easy for me to try to put
all these things together like you know
kobayashi on the cup oh my god you know
the usual suspects whatever but they're
the Red Door hub in the sixth sense I
was there all along but my interest in
Japan also this the elegance and
minimalism of Japan which have been
obsessed with obsess is a strong word
but I think it applies here for so long
I think it's just the the elegance and
of course you know in Japan you have the
elegance of certain artwork and the
minimalism you also have the efficiency
I mean we're talking about a country
that I think it was during the Meiji
Restoration brought in work workplace
efficiency and manufacturing efficiency
experts who had been largely ignored in
the US and elsewhere and the Japanese
would bring them to Japan and then
create say the entire corporate and
manufacturing design culture of Toyota
which ultimately then displaced US
automotive companies then later on right
they they they took what was ignored
incorporate it made it better made it
their own and then at least at that time
one right so all of that was so
interesting to me and
the literature of fact just as a side
note and it's not really a side note
because it kind of in my mind proves the
point when I took that class without any
perceptible additional effort my grades
and every other class went up and I
think it's because the old thinking the
sharper thinking translated to every
other class and and so at what point is
your ability to like control your own
journey coming in to play where you can
start to live the way you want to live
as an artist because you you had that
from the drawing and elegance and also
the the ability to navigate the business
side so you weren't dependent on others
yeah I I can give you I can tell me I
tell you the moment in my life I have
felt the richest I've ever felt and this
will relate to everything you just said
so little little backstory so what were
my jobs in college to help pay for
expenses and everything else well I had
I had a bunch of jobs one was I was an
illustrator so I did work I did
illustration illustration work including
for a Princeton University so for say
there was a was a Student Orientation
manual that that needed illustrations so
I did almost all the illustrations for
that there was I think there are one or
two books that I also did illustrations
for and not my preferred type of
illustration there's mostly backgrounds
and architecture on campus and so on
which is not terribly exciting to me I
preferred doing live action figures and
so on humans animals but nonetheless
there's that then for fun this is not
part of the job but relevant I was the
graphics editor at the Princeton tiger
and the primary reason I took that job
which was fun and it allowed me to just
goof off and be a bit of a prankster as
a satire magazine much like the Lampoon
was that I went to visit the offices of
the Princeton tiger and they showed me
the the desk of the graphic editor okay
I didn't realize there's a designated
desk for the graphics editor whatever
the title was at the time and I opened
one of the drawers and I found a number
of drunken sketches from Jim Lee one of
my comic book heroes man unbeknownst to
me at the time had gone to Princeton had
had that job and after some revelry had
come back to the office sketched out
some drinks and I said yeah I'll take
this job and so that was a job but
unpaid then I had a job in guest library
which was I've gone from you know the
pieces are coming together because
you'll do a blog and you won't get paid
for it
yeah but you know there's something
Goods gonna come out of this yeah we're
good for yeah good for other people or
fun for me or both and I had a job a
guest library which was the library the
attic as I remember at least the Attic
library of the East Asian Studies
department and it was terrible it was
like living in a Sun it was so hot up
there and I was getting paid whenever
was seven eight dollars an hour then I
was asked so by this point that's no
longer 100 pounds
I had really gotten into physical
training and was whenever I was at the
time actually bigger than I am now so I
was probably a hundred eighty hundred
and ninety pounds and one of my friends
said you know if you if if you want to
make some more money
you should safeguard now safeguarding is
bouncing but at Princeton they call it
safeguarding and Princeton s is very odd
tradition of eating clubs which are like
co-ed social clubs referred to think of
them as fraternities and sororities
combines these co-ed
clubs where you as you would expect eat
your meals where they serve lunch and
dinner and so on and they're all lined
up down one Street called Nassau Street
and so at least when I was there
students would go out and party and get
raucous on Thursday nights and Saturday
nights for whatever reason those were
the nights Saturday makes sense
not sure why Thursday is a day of
recovery so Thursday and Saturday and
things would happen people would get
invites people would get overly you know
men would get overly aggressive with
women whatever it would be so they hired
security guards to help keep the peace
and there were two I remember two
different safeguarding agencies as it
were and I chose I ended up working with
one that paid I think 20 dollars an hour
which to me at the time I'm like wow
thanks I'm hitting the big time so
twenty dollars an hour and long story
short did not enjoy that job I was good
at it but I didn't enjoy it because
you're nobody's friend nobody likes the
security when they're drunk yeah doesn't
matter even if you're actually helping
them and one of my very good friends at
the time who was I want to say former
former middleweight amateur boxing
champion in the Soviet Union which is a
very big deal very very big deal I mean
that's a that that's a you know
effectively a professional level boxer
and he was a physics graduate student at
Princeton I imagine that right it makes
sense
on some level a comic book character
soar it's fantastic guy
I named Elia so if you're out there yeah
thank you for being such a good friend
when we were in school and he was I was
off-duty I was not working on a given
night when he was we worked together a
lot because I trusted him he trusted me
and we were good at the job we could
hand and good at the job does not mean
fighting people by the way thank you the
good job means you don't you fight Yeah
right
defuse situations that would have fights
and you handle simple logistics like
there was this one eating club called
Tiger Inn which was known as being one
of the more aggressive eating clubs a
lot of football players a lot of big
athletes love very heavy drinking
culture and so as a safeguard you tended
to get paid the most when you worked at
say ti as it was known or some of these
other more aggressive spots because if
you're just going if you just got like
saving the computer science nerds from
each other if that's a that's a much
lower risk got a situation right and
there were at least two doors with
primarily front door which everybody
tried to come through and we would check
IDs and then there was a side door and
so you typically have one guard each
which worst which were not separated by
a ton of space and Elia was working with
someone that night who for whatever
reason left his post left the side door
wide open and there were a number of
there were a number of throwers meaning
track athletes who were shot Porter's
and discus throwers and hammer throwers
and so on who were visiting for a track
meet that weekend and a whole gang in
them huge guys I had shown up at the
front door and Elia had turned them away
because I didn't have IDs that's part of
the job and they got really upset and
they were like we're coming back okay
what happens they come around the side
door and like one guy grabs him by the
neck from behind another guy sort of
punches him in the liver and I mean this
is it doesn't matter if you're Mike
Tyson he's like five or six 230 plus
pound guys wailing and kicking you oh
man he ended up in really bad shape and
that that's when I stopped safeguarding
because I said to a it's kind of like
motorcycle riding this matter how good
you are on the motorcycle because there
are other people who are bad at driving
similarly it doesn't matter if you're
Bruce Lee Mike Tyson combined
if you're working a two-person
configuration and one person leaves a
side door no control no cattle no
control zero you're done okay whoa whoa
whoa we got a pause now cuz Kevin the
manager tells me it's time to talk about
the people who make all this possible
our sponsors you know I am so relaxed
because I just solved a problem that's
been bothering me for a long time I've
got this website now it was good but I
always wanted to customize it make it my
own and then I was introduced to
Squarespace when they became part of
this podcast it's amazing they allow you
to customize everything with beautiful
templates looks great on mobile and it's
easy to use so right here right now I'm
telling you I'm taking down the old
website and putting up a new one with
Squarespace I'm a free man
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code
busman to save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain enjoy
you know I talked with companies about
hiring in the interviewing process all
the time so I know how busy people are
and how difficult and time-consuming
finding the right candidate can be
that's why I was overjoyed to have zip
recruiter be a part of this podcast with
zipper cruder you can post your job to
more than 100 top job boards and just
one click within minutes of your post
zip recruiters smart matching technology
will notify qualified candidates about
your job but here's what I really love
unlike other hiring sites zip recruiter
doesn't depend on the right candidates
finding you it finds them that's why
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day and
check it out anyone who hears me right
now can post jobs on zip recruiter for
free just go to zip recruiter dot-com
slash Bussmann fu SS ma n zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire and we're back
so I stopped safeguarding and I started
that's the moment where you're really
gripping control over your over your
life oh no no I'm gonna get there so I
realized that I didn't want to go back
to $8 an hour in the sauna library I
needed money so what could I do now I
should also say simultaneously with all
of this like my interest in
entrepreneurship has increased because
there were some entrepreneurship classes
at Princeton which I one of which I
joined at the same time as McPhee's
class which was later called high tech
entrepreneurship which had a huge huge
impact on my life with someone named ed
Chou who is a real mentor but even
before that what I'd started doing as I
was making a little bit of money bussing
tables and so on is I would call the
numbers this is something I didn't do as
a kid still went going to sleep at 3
a.m. right so I'd see these infomercials
and I would call the numbers and I had
figured out how to take a tiny little
micro cassette recorder and go to Radio
Shack and I could Rick I know this is
probably illegal but so don't try this
at home kids but I could connect it to
record conversations because I wanted to
know what the scripts were it's like
okay well I knew what happened on the TV
what happens when you call and if I say
no if they try to convince me and then I
say oh it's $29.99 yeah I can't afford
that what happened
what do they say what do they do and
then if they send something to me if if
I if I buy something which I didn't do
until college so I sin college then I
was like all right well let me try to
buy let me order something and if I
what's the return process if I send it
back what happens oh man if I cancel
what happens how quickly does it get to
me
do they use first-class mail or do they
use Priority Mail do they use UPS I
wanted to just I just was so I wanted to
know the details and ultimately I had I
have something really I don't know how
common it is I don't have dyslexia
I can read fine but I have some
dysgraphia so DS B's and a getting mixed
up or peas and B's get mixed up let I
will write letters backwards or upside
out I still do to this day in English at
least and so I had also realized at
Princeton so I have I have some some
issues with producing text reading text
a little less so but the reading volume
this is going somewhere was so high at
Princeton if you were actually going to
do the classroom reading which I'm
convinced eighty percent of people do
not which is fine but I at the time felt
like that was a requirement for doing
well in school now certainly learning
and becoming a better human and a
liberal arts education should probably
be the priority but ultimately students
want to do well and anyone who's gotten
into Princeton is probably very
competitive so I was I was struggling to
do all of this reading there's so much
and towards the end of high school and
then leading into Princeton where you
know on my [ __ ] on my floor in Forbes
which is one of the residential colleges
I remember kids man kind of explains a
lot that goes on in our world when these
people then go onto goldman sachs and
stuff but they're like oh you got 1,800
on your SAT yeah me too what did you for
this and so all these kids are my on my
hallway got perfect scores on their SATs
which i did not i actually was my
SATs were much lower than the average
for Princeton didn't finish that my
switch of a perfectionist
actually never finished the test and I
took it multiple times so we could we
could psychoanalyze that but this is all
going somewhere
so I compensated in a way once I got to
Princeton by continuing to look at
accelerated learning and speed reading
techniques so could you accelerate your
reading speed without sacrificing
comprehension and there's a lot of
Voodoo and witchcraft and nonsense out
there but there are a handful of methods
for increasing reading speed that make
perfect sense if you're just looking at
the at the at how the eyes function and
how they feed into the optic nerve and
how one through fixation points and so
on cicada Commitments I think is how you
pronounce also the jumps that reading
entail reading entails made scientific
sense to me like the mechanisms were all
plausible there wasn't any hand waving
it's like okay know that just like
structurally make sense to me
so yes efficiency again so it's like
alright well if you're if your eye
travels across a line and let's say you
close one eye and you try to read a line
of text you'll notice these herky-jerky
movements all right
those are these saccadic movements jumps
from fixation point to fixation upon
your eye doesn't travel in a smooth line
across say a sentence on a page just
does not and if you can then reduce the
number of fixations you have per line
well if you go from three to two use
justing the line your smooth in line and
you're just going to move a lot faster
so I began doing that for myself and
after my friend got his head kicked in I
said well what if I took all this stuff
that I've been taking notes on so I've
always been a compulsive note-taker so
all the all of the infomercial stuff
another thing that I ended up doing at
that time was and I didn't come up with
this I had I had heard it or read it
somewhere I started to create a
three-ring binder where if I if I were
reading a magazine or an article and I
found an advertisement that made me want
to buy
something I would take it out and I
would put it into a three-ring binder to
try to figure out why it made me want to
buy it so I had all of these all of
these expedition findings kind of like
the butterfly and the butterfly species
and so on that Darwin or someone would
collect to analyze later but in my case
they were advertisements that made me
want to buy something and then I would
later try to deconstruct why they made
me what I was just looking into the
whole process of the business side yeah
but I hadn't pulled the trigger I hadn't
really tried anything that's not
entirely true I tried something but a
few years before that I think it was the
very beginning of Princeton which did
not work which was an audio book on how
to get into good colleges and I made a
bunch of mistakes the first of which was
coming up with a product I was convinced
would sell a million copies and not
testing not testing it before
manufacturing so I took all the money I
made from all this bus buying and so on
and invested it in manufacturing and 400
audio cassette tapes or something like
that I think one or two of which I sold
one to my mom I think it was she had
bought it and then later told me but and
then one to God knows who
so it was a huge loss I didn't throw out
those tapes until like ten years later
by the way I was like someday no someday
people will see realize the gold in this
a total failure
and then I I realized that I could
looking at these various advertisements
and so on do what's called a dry test
and that means you are selling something
before you manufacture anything secondly
based on buying little things here and
there and listening to and the the phone
the phone scripts right because these
operators use decision trees and these
scripts like if some if the person says
no to this do this if they say yes to
this do this if they say yes then try to
upsell them to this they say no they try
to down sell them to this
and if they agree to blah blah blah then
at the very end offer them this if very
at this point they say no I can't do it
then you offer them payment terms if
whatever it might be so they're all
these different contingency plans and I
put together I think it was called this
is right before yeah this was right
before the dot-com bust so this was like
90 98 99 and I think I called it speed
reading 2.0 or something like that or
enhanced speed reading it's I can't
remember the exact name and I I put out
this flyers so I printed out these
colorful flyers and I promised a a 300%
increase it was a 300% increase in
reading speed which you can measure
words per minute reading speed in a
three-hour seminar or you got it this is
the 4-hour work yeah this is the
foundation of it yeah or you get you get
you get a hundred and ten percent of
your money back so if it doesn't work if
it doesn't work you make money right so
you're going to completely weren't
deterred by those original cassettes
because I had no out-of-pocket
out-of-pocket expenses right so this is
a this is a service which ultimately is
why I stopped doing it but this is a
service so I then proceeded just so that
I wouldn't be caught with my pants down
if it actually worked which I didn't
expect it would necessarily but my
downside was so was so limited that it
didn't matter it was an asymmetrical
risk for a war benefit right which is
always when I look for you into this
stay it's like all right how can I count
my downside in fact if I always count my
downside if I have them if I can really
minimize downside eventually the upside
will take care of itself and if I have
enough at-bats so so the so I had these
Flyers all over the place and then I had
my I guess my dorm room phone number I
don't think I had a cell phone at that
point and my email address but I had to
find a location I couldn't afford a
location
Hix I wasn't safeguarding any longer and
I had $8 an hour so it's all right
there and I don't think there was any
date on the flyer because I won the
flexibility of like figuring out how to
finagle some type of space and I found a
church in town that had a I want to say
it was a daycare area for four kids that
would not be used on Saturday afternoons
there was some period of time in which
that was available and so I went in god
I haven't thought about this in a long
time and I tied I tied it a little bit
it wasn't very much but like I tied some
money to the church and I said I've
noticed you have this space and I was
just trying to put two and two together
and it's like is there any time when
this is not used and is there any
possibility I could use it up a first
time or not a first time in a cinema
aspiring entrepreneur trying this class
I explained the whole thing I said I
don't know if it's gonna work
it might not could be two people could
be more I have no idea but would it be
possible to potentially use this space
for a few hours
and I'll leave it in better shape then I
found it when I leave and thankfully
they took I guess mercy on me or
whatever you had some empathy and they
let me use the space or they said I
could use the space and and then at that
point emails and calls started coming in
so now I'm now I have to sell on the
phone well the stuff that you learned
from the and guess what I've already
listened to a hundred operators sell on
the phone who are backed by companies
that are spending tens and hundreds of
millions of dollars on ensuring that the
scripts work
man and I was beautiful so I end up my
first seminar with I want to say was
just for the sake of simplicity 30
people so I have a full room of people
30 people and they they come with cash
you know they've got tens and twenties
and fives they come with checks and not
a single refund so I'm I survived my
first three hours I deliver the
measurables right so the key performance
indicator for you startup folks out
there the words per minute rate with
equal or better attention at least in a
tripled or or in many cases quintupled
and I just remember walking out of that
seminar with pockets full of checks and
twenties and tens I mean I made $1,500
in three hours so keep in mind like I
had made the most I had made up to that
it was twenty dollars an hour doing
something it was risking life and limb
right and then I go into this church
daycare room and I walk out with fifteen
hundred dollars
there it is and I just remember and I
couldn't even fit them in my pockets I
remember I had to like fold up checks
your bow your pockets are both yeah I
had just full I had to fold them while I
was on a bike and I remember going
straight to PNC Bank it's my first bank
account just immediately as I have to
deposit these right away and going
straight to the bank and having money
and checks pressed to the grips on the
handlebars because they couldn't fit in
my pockets so I had these death grips on
my bike as I went to PNC Bank and
deposited that and I mean it it really
was that day where I was like holy [ __ ]
this could actually work you actually
can do this and I did a handful more of
those seminars but ultimately realized
you have to be in one place to do this
right it's a service right so it's still
on some level is physical presence hours
and money out and so I stopped doing
that when I graduated and so the that
moment and what
might happen with money that sounds like
a springboard in it in itself because up
until that point had you ever invested
in anything no no no actually you know I
head with the help of my dad invested in
one company and you know man
if I think about it like my investment
approach hasn't changed that much Pixar
was my first ever investment whoa
because what's that make sense when
you're the artist is the comic book
artist I loved it I loved animation so I
knew I felt like I understood the world
of comic books and animation really well
Pixar was coming out with Toy Story and
that's your first investment and that
was that was the first investment I ever
made the only investment that I recall
making until much much much later mean
well after college I I I don't like
things I can't control like public
stocks right I didn't feel like later I
overcomplicated investment for myself I
read a lot of books on investment and it
scared me off whereas in fact my best
investments to date have whether it's
like yeah Facebook Twitter who were
Alibaba all these because I really
really I play in those sandbox it's like
I understood them so well and I used
I've used all of them right yeah Pixar
was was my only investment small amount
of money and no nothing up to that upper
to that point in terms of external
investments invested a lot in myself but
well I came into this thinking that you
were a one-man partnership but I see now
that there are like five different
people doing all these different things
having all these different talents but I
enduro sees and difficulties and
weaknesses which might explain all the
voices in my head you know and and so at
what point is it that the 4-hour
workweek is going to be born
like the is there a moment in your mind
where we could see where everything is
leading in that direction but is there a
moment where you know there it is
the lifestyle or the book
well it sounds like the lifestyle led to
the book
well the lifestyle was was experienced
and enjoyed and then somewhat forgotten
so I had that experience with the
seminar then I became intoxicated by the
possibility of tech millions and
billions because this is keep in mind
all 99's in your hand and this was also
when a I'm not gonna say classmate but
schoolmate a few years ahead of me had
sold Blue Mountain calm for something
like three or four hundred million
dollars and there were a number of other
examples like that I mean this is
certainly at the top of froth and right
preceding the first tech boom and those
numbers were mind-boggling to me right I
mean it's one thing to make fifteen
hundred dollars it's it's quite another
thing to make four hundred million
dollars but some things should be
pointed out here the same way you were
talking about growing up in the era of
Schwarzenegger and Van Damme you're
growing up in the air of yeah a kid in
college starting something that can make
four hundred million dollars oh yeah I
mean those were the those were the new
heroes right and I took this class I had
mentioned earlier high tech
entrepreneurship with EDI which I which
I had to negotiate with him to get into
you because I had been this is highly
relevant so I don't a little tie-in but
I had I had gone to China and as an East
Asian Studies major as first
neuroscience and there's a long story
behind the trance the transition but I
do actually think some animal testing is
very very important but I couldn't do it
myself it wasn't torture it was
what they would call perfusing rats
after injecting them with retroviruses
and so on I couldn't sacrifice the
animals necessary to to do that to work
in the lab I want to work in so I became
an East Asian Studies major nonetheless
taking all of these other classes like
McPhee's class and at the same time edge
Chou enters the picture and his class
along with McPhee is were in I want to
say this book was the something like the
student class review guided that's not
the right name it was something like
that so it was similar to a registrar's
list of classes you could take but it
was an analog version of say Yelp so
students could actually rate these
classes and give feedback and edge house
class was along with McPhee is way way
up at the very top of the heap and he
was teaching people how to build
businesses how to build companies they
could get sold for hundreds of millions
of dollars but I had as an East Asian
Studies major taken time to go to China
to study at two universities and I came
back and I missed the deadline I'd
missed the deadline for applying so I I
wrote a letter to Professor Xiao I said
I'll do anyway i'm ii nye made my case
and ultimately said I don't need it I
don't need a seat if the rooms fall I
can sit on the floor if you need me to
help I can I can clean the erasers after
class like I will do whatever is
necessary how could you say no please
let me take this class and eventually he
did so he let me take this class and
that class led me to want to jump in to
the tech world and there was one class
I'm sorry one company that he hadn't
invested in called truce and networks
which is a storage area networking
company so he at the time what would
have been considered master data storage
so petabytes and petabytes of data oh my
god you know who could imagine now you
can go to now you can go to Fry's
Electronics and buy you know a terabyte
for
seventy dollars but back in the day we
were talking about 100 systems worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
millions of dollars that you'd be
selling to say American Airlines or to
the FBI or whoever it might be
National Geographic survey and in that
class we had to do a final project there
are different options for what types of
final projects you could do one was
profiling a company so I decided to
profile true San as a way to hopefully
get my foot in the door and get a job
yeah
long story short did the whole did the
whole final project and tried to get the
job then was turned down and graduated
with no job Paris but after all those
parents were terrible parents were very
supportive they're like okay aqtime you
can come home but for myself even after
a month or two of no job after
graduation starting at Nancy Nancy and
panicky so every every maybe two weeks I
would be emailing this poor CEO Thomas
actress Ann to try to get my foot back
in the door to get a job and I had heard
all these stories of negotiation and so
on from IDI also in this in this class
because he taught at Harvard Business
School and he and he used the case study
method so we were looking at real
stories of real companies tough
decisions they had to make and then the
class each student in the class as a
whole who would debate what they would
do given this decision the company or
persons facing and then you get to read
about what actually happened so
rejection no no thanks sorry we have an
in-house Human Resources person they are
completely backed up we have more
applicants than we can handle
thanks but no thanks he was very polite
about it considering how but no no no no
no no no no and then I was I was I was
going to give up and I was like you know
let me just try one more Hail Mary and I
sent him an email which was along these
lines and hi Thomas
I I realized I left out a few pay
competitive analysis in my final project
which was true
that could relate to you how you compete
with network appliance and emc those are
the two primary competitors as it turns
out this was the part that wasn't true
as it turns out I'm going to be in the
Bay Area anyway they were based in San
Jose I have a couple of job interviews
and meetings would it be possible to
swing by and give you these pages and
just thank you for the time that you
spent with me when I was doing the final
project which of course he could read
right through I would imagine so
and so you were you were fly back once
again politely sorry thank thanks but no
thanks appreciate the persistence but we
don't have space then he had a change of
heart he said ok I can meet you from I
can beat you on Tuesday I think this is
the exact time from 1 to 1:15 I was like
oh ok right hey I'll see you there so I
couldn't I didn't have the money cuz I
had I mean I burned through any of the
savings from the speed-reading stuff
didn't have a whole lot of money so I
bought a standby ticket to come up to
California on a standby ticket you don't
at least at that time you didn't check
luggage so I had carry-on only which
meant I wore my only my ill-fitting suit
like the only suit I had couldn't afford
hotel so I stayed at a kickboxing gym ok
for those of you in San Francisco this
might make sense there was a gym called
fairtex
which was located on Clementina Street
this is in 99 probably 99 mm between
fifth and six between Folsom and Howard
that's not a good place to be it was bad
like a really bad place but it was
cheaper than staying at a hotel to pay
for a fly in kick boxing camp and you
got to live on the upper floor sleeping
on a bunk bed with some of the Thai
instructors which meant I also had to
clean my clothing in the sink there
which I did and it was fine I didn't
have any other meetings so I very much
hastened to set up other meetings so
that I wouldn't feel like I had all my
eggs in one basket but now I had
something real to hold on to hey I have
an interview and say
minute I withdrew sin yeah while I'm
there I would love to chat with bla bla
bla so I was able to actually set up a
couple of meetings and got there at one
o'clock and Tom was delayed I was like
all right
one one one o'clock comes and goes one
fifteen comes and goes 1:30 comes and
goes and the receptionist I think my
name was Carly God she was a sweetheart
she was awesome - she was really not a
receptionist she was really the I mean
what we would call probably chief of
staff now that term didn't exist then in
startups she was amazing and she said
all right well Tom's delayed but he'd
love for you to meet with mark so I met
with Mark who was the CEO oh if I
remember correctly great guy and we
chatted for 30-40 minutes however long
it was foots in the door
yeah and eventually met with Tom and it
was a very short meeting nice to meet
you nice to see you again because he'd
met me he'd spoken with class and he
said so let me get this just so I'm
clear you're not gonna stop bothering me
until I give you a job and I said yeah I
suppose that's about right he goes okay
great you're in sales so I was the I
found out later the second to lowest
paid employee at the company Louis they
did not one of their like part-time
receptionist's okay because later one of
my friends asked for his paid time off
and so someone sent him a spreadsheet
with the other names deleted this is not
what you do by the way if you're sending
someone their paid time off but it was
an Excel spreadsheet and they'd
forgotten to delete another tab which
had everyone else's compensation in
stock options so my friends like dude
you need to see this but I was I got the
job and that came later but I didn't
have space for me so I would now you're
and say I was crammed into a desk in a
fire exit literally like in that tiny
doorway in a fire exit and then I had my
I think we called them systems engineers
who were support for technical sales
which I would be Brian
it was a really good guy and ya got to
it now that job ultimately disappeared
because the company like so many at the
time imploded rapid growth 9/11 happens
financing starts to dry up and but yeah
he's got another piece to the puzzle
here it's all the death knell so around
that time I saw the writing on the wall
and I said okay this is going away
what else do I know like I knew the
speed ring at the time and what I did is
this is I'll try to keep it short but I
looked at my one of the things I did is
I looked at my credit card statements to
determine how how I spent money where
did I spend the most money where was I
price insensitive like for the small
amount of money I was making in the Bay
Area which was at that time it's still
extremely expensive I mean it was
because there was so much demand right
there was less supply than demand so I
had roommates and the whole nine what do
I understand what could I make that I
myself where I'm price insensitive so I
could go high-end and that's supposed
alone and it was sports nutrition so
athletic nutrition and then during lunch
hours began using the conference lines
in empty rooms at Troost and to try to
lay the groundwork for this new company
that I would make and I mean I didn't
have the money or the connections for
anything but I did realize through all
the cold calling that I did to CEOs and
CTOs or the people I needed to sell to
for my job that 9:00 to 5:00 is the
worst time to make phone calls you
either want to call well end or 7:00 in
the morning
yes 7:00 in the morning or like 6:30 at
night because very often the people who
started the companies that the
president's the CEOs whoever were there
earlier they're late and the gate curt
the gatekeepers were not so I started
connecting with people in this black box
of sports nutrition who really liked to
keep it a black box for many many
reasons because there are contract
manufacturers who make different
products for competing brands and so on
started to figure
out and I had a just enough kind of
neuroscience background and also
certainly experiences consumer to know
when I wanted and then asked all of my
co-workers who also were I mean smart
enough to see the writing on the wall
like wow alright if a bunch of inside
sales people have been sold I've been
fired rather who kiss in some ways
you're sold other companies but who had
been fired inside meaning they book
meetings for people like me
their job is outbound phone calls but
they don't leave the office if a bunch
of inside salespeople have been fired
it's just a matter of time before all
the outside people are fired right so
this is just the first round of layoffs
and I asked them I said hey guys I think
we all know where this is going I'm
trying to start a new company like if I
have to I'll guilt you but can you
please just commit to buying one bottle
each all right so what did this give me
then I have 20 of my friends who commit
to buying one bottle of something that
doesn't exist yet
which gives me just enough money get the
craft you before you sell that product
yeah yeah you need to get the crowd
because then you've tested the market
right so are these people willing to
actually spend their money to buy this
thing I'm thinking about making
ultimately through gilts hopefully
product features and benefits they
agreed to do it and that gave me just
enough money which was like 20% of what
I actually needed to do a manufacturing
run to give me the confidence that I
could then and go negotiate and pitch
the manufacturer to have them drop their
minimum to what I could afford excited
my he laid out the vision for what this
could be
and then I'd stick with them as a
manufacturer and it's a bet but it's a
low-risk bet for them it would make a
huge difference I'm sure someone helped
you and you were just getting started
there's probably one person you can
remember please just give me that one
chance and they were very kind they
greed and I kept true to my word the
company exploded and I stuck with them
and then they made a lot a lot a lot of
money because of it ultimately so just a
flash forward so that company what I
thought was going to be a dream ended up
becoming a nightmare the company ended
up running me instead of the other way
around
I didn't know how to manage I did not
know how to scale without myself
remaining a bottleneck very different
from having a seminar which is very
simple fewer moving pieces and I burned
out and I lost a very important
relationship this girlfriend walked out
I had expected to probably propose two
and man I everything's going up in flame
everything's going up in flames now in
the meantime because I'm bootstrapping
this edge Shou had invited me to give
this lecture twice a year on how I was
growing my company you're up in flames
and now you're coming in to speak about
girl or God well now but keep in mind
the company itself was successful but I
fed you personally unsuccess right I got
it and I was certainly unhappy so the
mechanics of how to build I could teach
but the the inner workings and the
contentment and so on were a separate
conversation but I'm doing this twice a
year and the talk is changing as I'm
changing right and in 2004 which is when
all these things start melting down
I took a what I thought was gonna be a
four week trip one one-way ticket to
London to either rethink all the systems
in the business so that I could remove
myself as a bottleneck or shut it down
and it ended up working and I took notes
on all this I'm constantly keeping notes
right and started then imparting some of
this in these twice a year classes
lectures that I'm giving to students in
high tech entrepreneurship this class I
had taken and ultimately that four-week
trip turned into 18 months of traveling
around the world and I mean you know the
siren song of travel once you start yeah
it's addictive so I ended up with no
itinerary I'd run my whole life in 15
minute or 10 minute outlook increments
for so many years and now I had no plans
so if three people said what are you
doing here you should go to Galway in
Ireland because I have an art festival
okay I'll go to go away and so the
4-hour workweek is boy that's right so
I'm taking notes I'm taking notes and
all this I'm journaling and I remember
where I was exactly where it was I was
in a
I was in an apartment in a place called
barrio Norte in Argentina and wano site
is and I had a roommate from Sweden at
the time it's really funny dude with
dreadlocks black guy and he had given me
a couple hours to do the class via Skype
and I and I completely reformulated the
class and I focused instead of on how to
scale a business I talked about what I
termed lifestyle design so how do you
start with the end in mind for how you
want to spend your hours day to day in
this finite resource and how do you then
reverse engineer that with a company or
a career and no writer would everything
so I taught this class and one thing I
did for every class this won't surprise
you because if you'll recall I did all
these experiments with returning
products and everything so I would I
would one I would send a feedback form
to all the students and what and I would
ask them for different types of feedback
and then one of them was other comments
to have any other comments or
suggestions or questions and one of the
students in typical Princeton like
dickish fashion I don't think it was
actually a a real recommendation I think
it was just a snarky response said I
don't understand why you're teaching a
class of 30 students why don't you just
write a book and be done with it no oh
no but oh yes so that then keep in mind
yeah yes but what's what's what's my
situation at the time I have insomnia as
I did before I can't go to bed until
3:00 in the morning what don't you have
in Argentina I didn't have TV so my mind
would race and come up with potential
book I didn't want to write a book I had
a very horrifying experience with my
senior thesis in college so I had never
wanted to write I had vowed I would not
write and but to get to sleep I had to
write down these chapter ideas and what
I thought were just frivolous ideas for
chapter beginnings endings points I
could make stories I could tell about
all these people I'd met during my
travels who in hitta mised
what I was talking about just to get to
sleep I took it out of my head and put
it on paper which is something I still
do today and finally end up back in the
u.s. I this huge stack of paper thank
God for insomnia thank God for insomnia
and I'll give I'll give thanks to Jack
Canfield here so so several years before
when I first moved to Silicon Valley I
had volunteered which is the best way I
think to to build the network quickly in
a place you don't know I had volunteered
for an organization called the Silicon
Valley Association of startup
entrepreneurs and they did events so I
started just whatever taking out the
trash the great thing about volunteering
is that most people because they're not
getting paid do the bare minimum or a
little less than the bare minimum but I
went in and I was like all right I know
I'm taking out the trash but ice tea
isn't refilled over there let me go
refill the ice tea literally that's all
I needed to do for the people managing
the event to be like that kids a
go-getter let's have him do more i
refilled the damn iced tea and within a
month or two they were inviting me to
planning meetings and then I said they
asked if anyone would like to volunteer
to spearhead the next event which met
inviting speakers and I raised my hand
and they let me do it so I got to invite
people I want to meet including someone
named Jack Canfield who co-created
Chicken Soup for the Soul we just sold
hundreds of millions of copies oh man so
I get back from the US I haven't
bothered Jack in any way I haven't asked
him for anything he's still friend to
this day by the way and I took some of
the notes and I was back in the Bay Area
had no idea what to do with my life I
was fine I wasn't upset I was very happy
guy at that point very content had cash
flow from the business and I sent him a
couple of notes I said jacking up this
student said this here's some of my
ideas what do you think I should do with
this I don't really want to write a book
but what are your thoughts and before I
knew it Jack was like all right I want
you to meet this guy Steve I want you to
meet this person Jillian I want you to
meet this other woman and he started
making introductions he said I think
it's great you should do it I could see
it working on Fox and Friends and he
started before I could say no making
introductions to potential agents and so
on and ultimately because I had the time
put together a proposal which is a
business plan
and which you're good at yeah which I'm
good at I'd learned how to do and I
guess you're seeing this from the bottom
of the business process first yeah I
could think about finding the market
who's the market right was it easier for
you to write the proposal or the book
the proposal by a by a by a thousandfold
yeah because the proposal sell it right
the book is teaching yeah those are very
different things and save my case you
know the book is easy the proposal like
it just shoots fear through me oh sure
yeah a lot of writers a lot of writers
don't like feel very uncomfortable
selling themselves but the thing the
easiest way or the reason that was easy
for me to overcome is realizing that to
sell effectively you don't have to over
promise you don't have to blow a lot of
smoke
you just have to state the facts using
the tools you already have which are
which is word smithing and logical
progression and all this stuff that you
would get from say it's not I think from
John McVie certainly from John McPhee
logical thinking right now you're just
taking out the things that are
extraneous that might hurt you
you're not covering anything up but
you're just talent you're presenting the
case like an attorney would and then the
most efficient way fish and compelling
way possible and so Steve Hanselman and
does that who is it would just moved
from being a superstar editor and
publisher to being an agent ended up
signing on for this wild ride and do you
have any idea where this is going at
this alley no no the book was rejected
20 I want to say 20s I lose track the
number sometimes it was either 27
somewhere between 26 and 29 times it was
it was rejected by editors and
publishers and what are you feeling when
these rejections come in it was leering
sales so rejections is normal it's it's
normal I also support my writer that's
devastating so what I had that they
didn't have and this is the reason
rather than feeling sad or rejected I
felt angry and righteous
which also by the way is a double-edged
sword that doesn't always work so well
but the reason I felt I felt I knew I
was right and I felt righteous and I was
just pissed at these people is because I
had data
I taught 20 classes I had feedback forms
I had the experience goods I knew I knew
it sold I knew it could sell and I knew
it worked more importantly right so it's
one thing to say sell medicine it's
quite another to go through all the
trials and so on to ensure that the
medicine works
I knew the medicine worked and they were
whatever you know what they're the
rejection letters in some cases are so
rude they're too stupid not all of them
my some people were very gracious and
looking back at the proposal which I've
done quite frankly does read a bit like
the chest puffing of an overconfident at
the time 29 year old which I was like it
is it is a little much like I'll be
honest like I could see why someone
who's very seasoned vet who's had 20
years in publishing would read it throw
their eyes all their eyes I can
understand that but many of them were
too lazy or stupid to ask any questions
and if they'd asked some questions they
would have realized this is a low-risk
bet with a high potential return that's
been tested and if they were investors
which they are by the way that's what
publishers are there are recruiting
talent and investing in talent like just
like a baseball team that they should
have taken that bet they didn't altom
utley crown just an imprint within
Random House at the time which I guess
is random penguin or whatever it is now
was my I could not make this up I mean
it sounds like a cheesy scene from a
movie that would from a screenplay that
would not get sold but last meeting in
New York so I've had a chance to refine
the pitch through all these meetings
what I'm getting we're just still
getting no no no no no no no no no no no
no thank you
no come back later very venture capital
I mean there's there's there're a lot of
similarities between publishers in which
capitalist a lot of polite kind of soft
nebulous knows like well maybe if it's
successful we want this guy for a second
book so I'm not gonna be too rude now
smart which is smarter than being rude
but ultimately Heather Jackson who was
the editor slash sort of talent scout
right because they're acquiring editors
and they are talent scouts they have to
find authors I had been contacted by
Steve and she set up a meeting where at
the time the the the decider was Steve
Ross and had this meeting like 20 people
in the room I mean it's just a kind of a
Death Star meeting much like people may
have experienced at say a CAA or WMA
right you walk in your way to say I
thought I was meeting with one person
why are there 20 people here at that
point I'm used to it though it's like
all right this is just how publishing
works and I went through the whole pitch
the whole nine yards and seemed to be
getting like head nods here and there
but I didn't I didn't feel like it was
there like this this day it was not
gonna be consummated like it was it was
close but it wasn't quite there and so
so I've heard this now from or Steve if
my agent has heard it from other people
and publishing her at crown at the time
that this is what made the difference so
at the very end Steve said all right
there might have been Heather was either
Steve or Heather but they said all right
well this has been a great meeting do
you have anything else to say or to ask
before I wrap up and I said yeah I do
and I said if you look at my track
record if you look at the things that
I've done I have never half asked
anything I have an extremely high pain
tolerance so if you take the small bet
on this book I will stop it nothing I
will kill myself
to make this a best-seller I will do
everything within my power I will find
other people who can help me with things
outside of my power to make this succeed
and there you see it on anybody's face
or reaction I looked straight Steve
because he was the one who's gonna make
the decision and there's a little pause
I said okay thank you very much and then
they bought the book in news cam I guess
a few days later a week later maybe they
bought it for a pittance which good for
them they should right
they're in a much more leveraged
negotiating position after 27 rejections
why would you be a premium and amazing
boom so that was and I remember when the
book came out and there was a lot of
course that I'm doing to make sure that
I am true to my word
I didn't expect it well the other thing
is you know get the crowd yeah
then yeah through this Ellen then you
just want to imagine that you were out
getting the crowd in the mean time well
there are different crowds too and that
is their different sets of customers
even for a single product so in other
words I knew that to sell to readers I
had to first sell to publishers and to
sell to readers you then have to also
sell through publishers to distributors
so I knew that I had to have a story and
material for all of those groups for the
book to succeed it wasn't enough to just
sell books to the end reader I had to
know who the customers were who enabled
the book to be shepherded to ideal
position and a retailer and he just
broke the bread the business cycle down
piece by piece
oh yeah and even when choosing covers I
took different covers I went to the
borders which no longer exists in Palo
Alto on University Ave and I found a
book that was the same size and the new
arrivals or the new nonfiction area and
I wrapped it with the different covers
and I did this between say 5:00 and 8:00
p.m. so primetime and I would sit there
and I'd keep track of how many times
each cover was picked up so I'd give
each one say 30 minutes and I'd compare
which cover got picked up the most and
no writer things like this yeah even the
even the title for our work week was not
the original title the original title is
terrible original titles lifestyle
hustling I mean none of this we might
not even be talking right now if that
had been the title so how did if that
title come into play I ended up actually
know what it was lifestyle hustling in
the proposal then it was drug dealing
for fun and profit which was the name
which was the tongue-in-cheek
the tongue-in-cheek name of my class
that's what I called the seminar because
of the sports supplements and I think it
was Walmart or Costco
someone did not like the title right
right so one of my customers before the
book could get to my readers did not
like the title so in retrospect thank
God for that they didn't like the title
and Crown had a bunch of ideas but I
don't like making when possible purely
emotional decisions based on some type
of consensus right I mean as they say or
I've heard at least you know a camel is
a horse drawn by consensus and I instead
said all right if we need a new title
give me some time I'll test it and at
the time it was the the the golden years
of Google AdWords which could be tested
very inexpensively and I grabbed about
ten different domain names right URLs
and then I had combinations of different
titles and subtitles and so I put those
I bid on different search terms like
retirement around the world travel
whatever it might be and then an ad
would pop up for my book that didn't
exist and it would have whatever
lifestyle huh slang as the ad headline
and then the ad text would be the
subtitle and then the link which would
be the URL for that particular book
title which I'd already reserved and
Google mixin matches those automatically
so you don't have to manually test all
the permutations and combinations and
for two or three hundred dollars
whatever it was maybe less 150 to 300
ollars within a week I knew that by far
what got the highest click-through rate
so it's the same as people picking up a
cover and me tracking the pick up rate
the highest click-through rate was
4-hour workweek an escape the
nine-to-five so on and so forth live
anywhere enjoying the new rich which
ended up being the title and subtitle
had by far the highest click-through
rate differential and standard deviation
and I took that data to the publisher
unless we ran with oh man number one I
got to start watching infomercials
number two I'm gonna have to run off to
interview Kobe Bryant yeah I'd say I
said it's important so what I would like
to if it's okay with you yeah stop here
let's make this Tim Ferriss the early
years Chuck chapter one chapter one and
then come back and do chapter 2 starting
with the phenomenal success of that book
may I give people a preview of where we
are now so much like say a movie we can
be into it you know in media rest and
then we can flash back hate to meet em
so this maybe people will do Star Wars
Episode four and then we could do three
and then we can do the prequels and well
the I think what has helped me to do to
achieve any modicum of success in these
various areas and I've certainly had
plenty of mistakes like the audio books
and so on is asking better questions so
first and foremost I like to thank you
for helping me to learn how to ask
better questions
so that's piece number one thank you
piece number two is that in many ways by
reading writing by people such as
yourself I started interviewing people
myself which I was doing for the books
and so the 4-hour workweek was the first
book the latest book is tribe of mentors
right so if you look back at these
people I had the absolute spectacular
luck to meet whether it's John McPhee or
it shall I can't wait to read this but I
am always asked what do you what can I
do if I don't have access to those
people so what I did was went out and
found a hundred and thirty of people who
are the best at what they do and ask
them the eleven or so questions that
have refined over several hundred
interviews to figure out what their
secrets are and whether that relates to
financial success investing physical
wellness training or otherwise it's a
compilation of profiles of people
ranging from you know the Maria
Sharapova's and
Kelly Slater's of the world world-class
athletes of all different types - heroes
of mine I wanted to reach out to like
Dan Gable who is a wrestling coach and
I'm so the McPhee equivalent in
wrestling I got is Gable so I
interviewed gable and so on all the way
to different types of writers people
like Steven Pinker and so on it sounds
amazing teasing out all of their play
books so for people interested in that
type of cheat sheet across every
possible domain you can imagine a tribe
of mentors is is the latest which should
be out by the time people hear this they
can they can find that tribe of mentors
calm and see sample chapters and the
list of all the mentors know everything
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday if that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric
as I do it could include favorite
articles that I have read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out just go to
4-hour workweek dot-com that's 4-hour
workweek calm I'll spell out and just
drop in with your email and you'll get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet Friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers and it's
super super simple
it does not clog up your inbox every
Friday I sent out five bullet points
super short of the coolest things I've
found that week
which sometimes includes apps books
documentaries supplements gadgets new
self experiments hacks tricks and all
sorts of weird stuff that I dig up from
around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long and that's
why I created five for Friday it's
become one of my favorite things I do
every week it's free it's always gonna
be free and you can learn more at tim
vlog forward slash friday
that's tim vlog forward slash friday i
get asked a lot how I meet guests for
the podcast some of the most amazing
people I've ever interacted with and a
little bit in fact I've met probably 25%
of them because they first subscribe to
500 Friday so you'll be in good company
it's a lot of fun by bullet Friday is
only available if you subscribe via
email I do not publish the comment on
the blog or anywhere else also if I'm
doing small in-person meetups offering
early access to startups beta-testing
special deals or anything else and it's
very limited
I share it first with 500 Friday
subscribers so check it out Tim blog
forward slash Friday if you listen to
the podcasts very likely that you'd dig
it a lot and you can of course easily
subscribe any time so easy peasy again
that's Tim vlog forward slash Friday and
thanks for checking it out it the spirit
moves yeah
this episode is brought to you by four
Sigma deck
you might remember forward sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades
I will largely fix that but still
shutting off my monkey brain has never
been easy still isn't easy very often
and I found reishi which have been
fascinated by it for a few years now has
been very very effective in calming
their old formula however for sig Maddox
old formula included stevia and I like
to avoid sweeteners all sweeteners for a
host of reasons and I then just ping
them and asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it if too much of a headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
and or nut milks such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
should take the advice of all Chinese
people when they're criticizing youngins
when they say boo and I'm sure cool
which means
you're not able to eat bitterness bitter
is in many cases an indication of things
that help liver detoxification and so on
not saying that's the case here but I've
tested this reishi lecture on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and know don't put in honey or nut milk
or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like to air that kind of stuff
that type of tea you're gonna dig it so
just try it okay
back to then my read if you'd like to
naturally improve your sleep both on set
and quality I think naturally you might
just enjoy this ratio lecture without
any sweeteners it has organic reishi
extract organic fueled myth extract
organic rosehips extract organic Tulsi
extract and that's it no fancy stuff no
artificial watching the call at anything
so check it out go to four Sigma tech
comm port slash ferrous and get 20% off
this special batch I don't know they're
gonna be making much more of this and
since it was made specifically for you
guys so do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for sig Matic that's fo you are SI GMA t
IC comm /e ferrous f e RR ISS and get
20% off a special batch and you must use
code Ferris to receive your discount fer
our ISS so again go to four Sigma to
comm forward slash Paris and then use
code Ferris for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any screeners enjoy